dreams without goals are just dreams
i just can't live my life based upon
what other people think about me
something you don't feel good about then
don't do it how many ghosts are going to
be around your bed when your time comes
you'll never see a u-haul behind a
hearse i got there
just by working hard to make sure you
have something to fall back on there is
no one discipline
there is no one uh gospel
well i will hand you the cup my dear the
cup will be there
to be handed to you i wanted to say
thank you
it was my way of saying thank you he's
an american actor
and filmmaker he's received two golden
globe awards a tony award and two
academy awards
in 2015 he received a lifetime
achievement award at the 73rd
golden globes he's denzel washington and
here are his top 10 rules for success
dreams without goals are just dreams
and they ultimately fuel disappointment
goals on the road to achievement
cannot be achieved without discipline
and consistency i pray that you all put
your shoes
way under the bed that night so that you
got to get on your knees in the morning
anything you want good
you can have so claim it
work hard to get it when you get it
reach back hold someone else up
each one teach one
don't just aspire to make
a living aspire
to make a difference you don't pay a lot
of attention to reviews and
those kind of things well you know
you're always affected by opinion but
the
the
the more opinions there are of you the
of
me the more i the less i look at them
because
i just can't live my life based upon
what other people think about me
so i can't concern myself too much with
what other people think you know it's
just not healthy
i don't think i can i could continue to
do what i do if i was constantly
worrying about what somebody thought
about it
you don't have to compromise yourself
you know if it's something you don't
feel good about then don't do it the
most important choices i've made
was to say no and i said no
many a time to to films that i just
didn't especially early on
i just didn't feel comfortable with uh
they they
there was one script that was brought to
me i called it the [ __ ] they couldn't
kill
because he was accused of raping his
wife
in the 40s and they they tried
so i actually called cindy who i was
fortunate at that time to instill to be
able to call
and i said you know this movie's making
i'm sick and they offered me six hundred
thousand dollars
to play the [ __ ] they couldn't kill
that's and
he said to me and i'll say this to you
he said the first
two or three or four films you make in
this industry denzel will determine how
you proceed
he said i'm not going to tell you what
to do but remember that
the first three or four or five films
you made will determine how you proceed
i turned it down i turned the money down
i needed the money
i turned it down six months later i got
cry freedom
so stick to your guns if you if you if
you
don't feel like you should do it then
don't do it
because you don't want to be you know
you don't want to be a negative
energy on the set that's how i feel so
i'm like you know i ain't doing this
because i'm going to slap somebody the
second day
so i just you know it's i think the most
important decisions you can make as an
active
actress is saying no they're saying no
you don't
have to take your clothes off
to get something you never had you have
to do
something you never did les browns a
motivational speaker he made an analogy
about this
he says imagine you're on your deathbed
and standing around your deathbed
are the ghosts representing your
unfulfilled potential
the ghost of the ideas you never acted
on the ghost of the talents you didn't
use
and they're standing around your bed
angry
disappointed and upset they say we
we came to you because you could have
brought us to life
they say and now we have to go to the
grave together
so i ask you today
how many ghosts are going to be around
your bed when your time comes
you'll never see a u-haul behind a
hearse
i'll say it again you'll never see a
u-haul behind a hearse now i've been
blessed to make
hundreds of millions of dollars in my
life
i can't take it with me and neither can
you
so it's not how much you have it's
what you do with what you have
and we all have different gifts some
money some love
some patience some the ability to touch
people but we all have it
use it share it that's what counts
not what you're driving not what you're
flying in not what kind of house you
brought your mama goodbye
the one thing i'm the most happy about
in terms of my career
is the fact that i got there the grace
of god first of all but short of that
i got there just by working hard not
partying with the right people
not compromising myself in any way
or cutting any kind of deals just by
working hard just by
plugging along sawing wood as i like to
call it
i'm a 20-year overnight sensation i
found that nothing in life
is worthwhile unless you take risks
nothing nelson mandela said
there is no passion to be found playing
small in settling for a life that's less
than the one you're capable of living
now i'm sure in your experiences in
school and applying to college and
picking your major and deciding what you
want to do with life i'm sure
people have told you to make sure you
have something to fall back on
make sure you got something to fall back
on honey
but i never understood that concept
having something to fall back on
if i'm going to fall i don't want to
fall back on anything
except my faith i want to fall forward
i figure at least this way i'll see what
i'm going to hit
fall forward this is what i mean
reggie jackson struck out 2600 times in
his career the most
in the history of baseball but you don't
hear about the strikeouts
people remember the home runs
fall forward thomas edison conducted one
thousand failed experiments did you know
that i didn't know that
because the one thousand and first was
the light bulb
fall forward every failed experiment
is one step closer to success bruce lee
you know studied many martial arts
and he talked he always said take what's
useful
so i've taken from different styles and
you know my my youngest daughter uh
olivia is an actress now she's at nyu
in fact she just finished her first
movie with uh yeah i tell her that you
know there is no one discipline
there is no one uh gospel
when it comes to acting so i take a
little from this take a little from that
i had breakfast with archbishop desmond
tutu and lunch with nelson mandela
wow and actually when he came to the
states yeah the last time he came
came to california came to our house
well that's pretty good
now you see this i'll tell you a funny
story too
you'll be mad at me for telling us but
i'll tell it anyway uh
sylvester stallone he lives up in the
we're like in a gated community he lives
over there
and he he wasn't invited he had
everywhere i mean i would have invited
him but yeah we had about maybe 40 50
people there you know and i had
my children i said you can invite one
friend and you know
oprah winfrey different people were
there and the security they had security
helicopters like it was the president
yeah
they're like mr washington uh rocky's
out front he's pacing
he's he's like looking in the gate like
i said should we he's like should we let
him in i'm like yeah that's the best to
come in
they said he was outside looking sad
like man
can you see rocky hey mr mandela
how you doing how you doing how you
doing yo adrian
mandela mandela over here
thank you so much for watching i made
this video because orion dark knight
asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next
leave it in the comments below and i'll
see what i can do i'd also love to know
which of denzel's top 10 rules meant the
most to you had the biggest impact
leave it in the comments and i'll join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon
you will fail at some point in your life
accept it
you will lose you will embarrass
yourself you will
suck at something there's no doubt about
it
and i know that's probably not a
traditional message for a graduation
ceremony but hey
i'm telling you embrace it because it's
inevitable
and i should know in the acting business
you fail all the time early on in my
career
i auditioned for a part in a broadway
musical
perfect role for me i thought except for
the fact that i can't sing
so i'm i'm in the wings i'm about to go
on stage
but the guy in front of me he's singing
like like
like pavarotti he's just wrong
and he's just going on and on and on and
i'm just shrinking i'm getting smaller
and smaller
so they say oh thank you very much thank
you very much and you will
you'll be hearing from us so i come out
with my little sheet music and
it was it was a just my imagination by
the temptations that's what i came up
with
so i hand it to the the the accompanist
and uh
she looks at it and looks at me and
looks out at the director and was like
all right so i i start you know i'm
gonna sing i'm like
it's just my imagination
once again and then coming away with me
and i'm not saying anything so i'm
thinking i'm getting better i
could start getting into it
running this oh yeah thank you thank you
thank you
thank you very much mr washington thank
you so i assumed i didn't get the job
but the next part of the audition he
called me back the next part of the
audition
is the acting part of the audition you
know i'm like hey
okay maybe i can't sing but i know i can
act so they pair me with this guy and
again i didn't know about musical
theater
and musical theater is big so they can
reach everyone all the way in the back
of the
of the stadium and i'm more from
realistic uh
naturalistic kind of acting where you
you know you actually
talk to the person next to you so i
don't know what my line was
my line was well hand me the cup and his
line was
well i will hand you the cup my dear the
cup will be there
to be handed to you
i said okay
well should i give you the cup back oh
yes you should give it back to me
because you know that is
my cup and it should be given back to me
i didn't get the job
but here's the thing i didn't quit
i didn't fall back
i walked out of there to prepare for the
next audition and the next audition and
the next audition
i prayed i
prayed and i prayed
but i continued to fail and fail
and fail but it didn't matter because
you know what there's an old saying
you hang around the barber shop long
enough sooner or later you're going to
get a haircut
so you will catch a break and i did
catch a break
last year i did a play called fences on
broadway
someone talked about it won the tony
award
and i didn't have to sing by the way but
here's the kicker
it was at the court theater it was at
the same theater
that i failed that first audition 30
years prior
the point is and i'll pick up the pace
the point is every graduate here today
has the training
and the talent to succeed but do you
have the guts
to fail i'm a father first i don't get
life mixed up with making a living
i was there for all four of my children
being born when the first one was born i
recognized the difference
between life and making a living their
life
you know our family is life you know
acting is making a living
what do you think the biggest difference
between doing a play and doing i mean
it's a cliched question but i'd be
interested to know your answer
i think a part of what biola just said
is that you get to dig deeper and you
get another day
and you get the energy you do a movie
and there's 200 people that are used to
it and they don't care and
everybody's doing their job and it comes
in a theater somewhere and
you know you're picking your nose at
home somewhere cut clipping your nails
there's no energy right when i was on on
broadway five years ago julius caesar
i made a decision to sign autographs
every night what i did
oh yeah it ain't happening this time
though
only as i rub my knees only because my
knees are bad it's hard
for me to stand but and why did you
decide to do that well you know
i wanted to say thank you it was my way
of saying thank you
and the first night it was like five
thousand people out there i said okay
wait a minute everybody who has play
bills
from our show so yeah cause it was like
people were just wandering up the block
i was like wait a minute i forgot i'm on
you know 42nd street times square
wait a minute but honestly you were
signing for what the energy
and i was out there hour and a half
every night every show but the energy
you got back the stories
the five little old ladies who who just
drove in from detroit
and i'm like well what y'all doing
tonight i said we getting back in the
car baby we got to go back tonight
and you know a little 84 year old lady
was like baby if i was three years
younger
oh true story then we had we
we had and and and and i say this also
because i hope it happens with this play
we had uh some high schools come
we had one school from somewhere i
forgot where and they were doing julius
caesar and
some young kid was like well you know my
brutus is a bit different
he's more the classic stoic but it was
great to engage
in in in in exchange with these young
people with
it was there was an energy i i got more
from it than i gave to
to the people that i signed for that's
you know
you don't get that uh you know the odd
thing about success in film is
is the budgets get bigger you make more
money but they become more formulaic so
you don't get the opportunity so
i god willing if i stay around long
enough this is what i'm going to be
doing